aquí tengo a esta matriz de hilo que
crece en este vídeo es calcular la
dimensión del espacio nulo de la matriz
b y bueno antes de calcular la dimensión
del espacio nulo de la matriz b hay que
recordar que es el espacio nulo y el
espacio nudos de una matriz la habíamos
definido de la siguiente forma como los
vectores x que viven en donde bueno en
este caso van a vivir en 1 2 3 4 5 en r
5 como los vectores que viven en r 5
tales que la matriz b x el vector x esto
tiene que ser igual al vector 0 así
habíamos definido el espacio nulo y
bueno para calcular primero el espacio
no lo que me voy a acordar es de un
resultado que habíamos sacado hace
algunos vídeos que el espacio nudo de la
forma escalonada de la matriz vean es
exactamente el mismo que el espacio es
nulo de la matriz b y esto me va a
servir bastante porque entonces lo que
voy a hacer es que escalonar la matriz b
entonces lo primero que vamos a hacer en
este vídeo es escalonar esta matriz ven
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es dejar
el primer renglón tal cual el renglón 2
sustituirlo con el renglón 2 no sé
random uno por lo tanto voy a dejar
el cual deje ese renglón 11 232 y en
lugar de poner el renglón 2 lo que voy a
poner es el renglón 2 no se rindió no
entonces me queda 1 - 1 0 1 - 1 0 3 - 2
1 1 - 3 - 2 y después 4 - 2 es 2
perfecto y bueno una vez que ya tengo
esta matriz ahora date cuenta que lo que
quiero es que este sea mi variable
pivote y por lo tanto tengo que quitar
este 2 de aquí para quitar este 2 de
aquí lo que voy a hacer es tomarme el
renglón 1 y sustituirlo por el renglón 1
- dos veces el renglón 2 por lo tanto
vamos a dejarlo en 2 tal cual 0 0
1 - 22 y el renglón 1 lo voy a cambiar
por el renglón 1 - dos veces el renglón
2 y dice 10 11 - 0 1
2 - 2 0
3 - menos 2 x 2 esto es lo mismo que 3 +
4 3 4 7 y 2 por 2 son 4 menos por menos
más 34 son 7 muy bien y después dos
menos 2 por 2 2 menos 4 lo mismo que
menos 2 muy bien ya tengo esta matriz y
qué creés esta ya es la matriz de la
forma escalonada debe aquí ya tenemos la
forma escalonada de la matriz ven y
recuerda que la voy a ocupar para sacar
el espacio nulo por lo tanto lo voy a
multiplicar por el vector x 1 x 2 x 3 x
4 x 5 y esto lo voy a hacer igual al
vector 0 0 y entonces que me va a quedar
pues me van a quedar las ecuaciones si
yo hago la multiplicación de esta matriz
por este vector me va a quedar una
primera ecuación que va a tener como
variable pivote x 1 es esta de aquí
estas dos son mis variables pivotes y me
queda 1 x x 1 + 1 x x 20 x x 3 pues eso
no se ponen más 7 x x 4 - 2
x 5 2 x 5 y esto es igual a 0 recuerda
que estoy trabajando con la primera
componente de estas ecuaciones ahora no
voy a tomar mi segunda ecuación y mi
segunda ecuación quién va a ser bueno
como esta de variable pivote entonces me
va a quedar 0 x x 10 x x 2 + 1 x x 3 - 2
x x 4 - 2 x x 4 + 2 x x 5 esto igual a 0
esta es justo ni otra ecuación que me
sale de mi vector resultante muy bien y
recuerdan que yo tras lo que iba era
tras las variables pivote como ya sé que
x 1 y x 3 son mis variables pivote
entonces déjame ponerlo de la siguiente
manera con el mismo color
voy a despejar tanto a x1 como x 3 así
que veamos x 1 es igual a menos x 2
menos 7 veces x 4 más 2 veces x 5 esto
de la primera ecuación y bueno de la
segunda ecuación voy a obtener que x 3
es igual a
2 veces x 4 a 2 veces x 4 menos 2 veces
x 5 está de la segunda ecuación y bueno
todo esto porque entonces ya sé cómo
puedo ver a todos mis vectores que son
parte de este espacio nulo todos los
vectores de la forma x 1 x 2 x 3 x 4 x 5
que forman un espacio nulo son de la
siguiente manera y bueno en lugar de
escribir a x1 y x 3 voy a sustituirlo
por sus respectivos valores que tengo
aquí entonces todo depende de x2 por un
vector más x x 3 no porque x 3 lo vamos
a poner entonces me queda x 4 x 4 la
siguiente variable que no es pivote + x
4 por otro cierto vector y por último a
esto lo voy a sumar más x 5 por otro
vector que ya no me cabe aquí así que no
es que esto se va a ver bastante feo
déjame mejor borrar esta ecuación porque
si yo aquí pongo todo amontonado no me
vas a entender entonces vamos a borrar
todo esto
déjame espera espera no se quiere pasar
déjame pasar lo del otro no no se puede
haber tomemos la goma y fue a borrar
todo esto lo voy a copiar primero aquí
abajo x 3 es igual a 2 x 4 menos 2 x 5 y
empezamos a borrar vamos a borrar todo
esto vamos a pensar que nada sucedió
para que así tenga espacio suficiente
para ponerte a este espacio nulo así que
borramos todo esto y ahora si x 2 por un
vector más x 4 por otro vector más x 5
por otro vector y bueno x 1 lo podemos
ver como menos una vez x 2 menos 7 veces
x 4 menos una vez
x 2 menos siete veces x 4 más 2 veces x
5 esto es lo que me dice la primera
ecuación estás de acuerdo ahora de una
vez utilizamos la información que
tenemos en la segunda ecuación x 3 mm
variable pivote y entonces la voy a
poner aquí como 2 veces x 4 menos 2
veces x 5 2 veces x 4 menos 2 veces x 5
entonces aquí va aún menos 2 y en x 2 0
pongámoslo porque aquí va un 0 y x2 pues
x2 no nos complicamos la vida x2 es lo
mismo que una vez x2 entonces voy a
poner una vez x 20 veces x 4 + 0 veces x
500 y x 4 pues lo puedo ver cómo una vez
x 4 entonces en lugar voy a ponerlo con
otro color si mejor vamos a poner con
otro color las otras variables 1 0 0 y
ahora voy a poner esta variable x 4 y x
4 lo puedo ver como 0 veces x2
una vez x 4 y 0 veces x 5 y por último x
5 lo puedo ver como 0 veces x 20 veces x
4 y una vez x 5 muy bien todo esto todo
esto lo estoy construyendo porque
entonces ya sé cómo se ve el espacio
nulo de la matriz ven date cuenta de
esto si nosotros llamamos a para no
hacerlo más complicado porque tenemos
vectores con cinco entradas vamos a
llamar a esto b1 b2 y b3 y entonces ya
sé que mi espacio nulo de la matriz de
que acabo de construir es exactamente
igual y déjame ponerlo aquí todos los
vectores x
estos que cumplen mi ecuación en px
igual al vector 0 es exactamente igual
al espacio nulo de la matriz a que es
exactamente igual al espacio nulo de la
forma escalonada la matriz a que es
exactamente igual al espacio vectorial
generado por estos tres vectores al
espacio vectorial generado por b1 b2 y
por b 3 y bueno aquí voy con todo esto
este ejercicio tuvo muy padre pero a
donde quiero llegar yo lo que quiero
construir en este en este vídeo es un
conjunto linealmente independiente y
entonces linealmente dependiente es
decir estos tres vectores son
linealmente independientes esa es mi
pregunta que ahora me quiero responder
es decir ya sé que mi espacio nulo ese
espacio vectorial generado por estos
tres vectores sin embargo lo que no sé
es si estos tres vectores forman una
base de este espacio en uno y es justo
por eso que necesito la independencia
lineal y bueno como se decisiones
linealmente independientes
en esto este vector uno tiene asociado
un 1 a esta variable el libre x 2 es
decir que si yo me preguntara si puedo
formar una combinación lineal con estos
otros dos vectores de tal suerte que me
den el vector 1 la respuesta es que no
porque cualquier combinación lineal de
estos dos vectores siempre me va a dar 0
en esta componente y nunca voy a poder
formar un 1 por lo tanto es
indispensable poner a este vector uno en
nuestro conjunto independiente sin
embargo ahora me puedo hacer la misma
pregunta para este vector 2 podemos
prescindir de este vector 2 es decir
haciendo una combinación lineal del
vector 1 y el vector 3 de tal suerte que
yo puedo obtener este vector 2 y la
respuesta es muy parecida a la pregunta
anterior si te das cuenta aquí en este
vector dos tenemos asociado un 1 a x 4
déjenos ponerlo con un color este 1 está
asociado en la variable x 4 y sin
embargo es la única forma de obtener
aquí un x 4 porque las otras dos
componentes asociadas a esta misma
variable tengo un 0 y otro 0 por lo
tanto no hay forma de encontrar una
combinación lineal
del vector 1 y el vector 3 que me den de
resultado el vector 2 y muy parecido
para este vector 3 date cuenta que aquí
tenemos un uno asociado esta variable
libre x 5 y por lo tanto no va a haber
forma de encontrar una combinación
lineal con la cual pueda obtener un 1 en
esta quinta componente por lo tanto me
estoy refiriendo a que estos sí son un
conjunto de vectores linealmente
independientes y mejor aún ya acabo de
demostrar que el vector 1 al vector 2 y
el vector 3 este conjunto de vectores
son linealmente independientes y además
generan al espacio nulo de la matriz b
por lo tanto son una base pues
precisamente lo que quería del espacio
nudo de la matriz am no espera
estábamos hablando de la matriz b de la
matriz de porque aquí tengo una a estar
medio raro teníamos una matriz b en un
principio por lo tanto aquí hay que
poner una vez es el espacio nulo de la
matriz b y este es el espacio nudo de la
forma escalonada de la matriz b perdón
un error de dedo muy bien pero lo
importante de todo esto es que aquí
tenemos un conjunto de vectores
linealmente independientes y qué
genera al espacio nulo de la matriz bay
por lo tanto es una base de el espacio
el mundo de la matriz ver pero bueno
aquí no acaba todo este asunto porque
realmente yo lo que quiero es
preguntarme sobre la dimensión de este
espacio nulo de la matriz ven y lo que
hice en el vídeo pasado fue una
demostración acerca de la dimensión de
cualquier sub espacio así que vamos a
recordar primero que era la dimensión de
un sub espacio y bueno la definición era
muy fácil es la cantidad de elementos es
el número de elementos la cantidad de
elementos que tiene una base de este sub
espacio y lo que vimos en la
demostración del vídeo pasado es que
siempre era la misma cantidad de
elementos para todas las bases de este
sub espacio cada una de ellas tienen la
misma cantidad de elementos muy bien
entonces así defino la dimensión de un
sub espacio entonces si me pregunto por
la dimensión del espacio nulo de la
matriz ven yo quiero saber la cantidad
de elementos que tiene cualquiera de las
bases del espacio no lo de la matriz b y
bueno aquí ya tenemos una base explícita
esta base tiene 123 elementos por lo
tanto la dimensión del espacio nudo de
la matriz b es igual a 3 y también a
esta dimensión del espacio nulo de la
matriz b se le conoce como la nulidad
nulidad de la nulidad de b en este caso
es 3 muy bien a esto podría llegar pero
también aquí tenemos una pequeña
reflexión porque tres son los vectores
que están aquí en esta fase del espacio
nuevo de la matriz ven sin embargo dt
cuenta que están asociados con las
variables libres aquí tenemos tres
variables libres y por lo tanto tengo
curiosamente tres elementos en el
espacio nulo de la matriz p por lo tanto
lo que quiero que veas es que la nulidad
de amd para cualquier matriz am la puedo
ver como la cantidad de vamos a poner de
esta manera la cantidad de variables
libres la cantidad de variables libres
que tengo en la forma escalonada de la
matriz a recuerda que esta forma
escalonada es muy importante en la
forma escalonada de la matriz a bueno es
que esto no tiene poco sentido no no
mejor lo voy a poner como la cantidad de
columnas no pivotes el número de
columnas no pivotes de mi forma
escalonada de la matriz a así que para
que no quede duda vamos a revisarlo el
número de columnas no pivote vamos a
subir esta pantalla para que te des
cuenta lo que hicimos aquí tengo mis
tres variables que son libres pero
realmente estas tres variables que son
libres salen de mis columnas que no son
pivotes en mi forma escalonada de la
matriz b por lo tanto vamos a fijarnos
en la forma escalonada de la matriz b
para ver si tienen la misma cantidad de
elementos y fíjate aquí tenemos 1 2 3
esta primera columna está asociada a x2
esta segunda columna está asociada a x 4
y esta tercera está asociada a x 5 es
exactamente lo mismo son la cantidad de
columnas que no son pivotes cotizó otra
manera mis variables libres espero que
hayas encontrado todo esto vagamente
útil